good morning belief nation today's
message is never lie about anything over
to you Sheldon Adelson I don't know I'm
outspoken because I am I could never
make it couldn't be a liar I can only
tell the truth I would be very been
there I say that my father told me my
father never left me with anything
material but he left me the richest as
rich as I could be with values and he
always told me never lie about anything
you got to be honest because if you lie
about one thing the second time somebody
is going to ask you you've got to make
up a lie to cover that first line and
then pretty soon you've got a whole
chain of lies and then you completely
exposed so this is an interesting one
for me I don't know if you can never lie
about anything I think it's something
that you can aspire to do and I think
sometimes a little lie might be okay you
know white lies if your wife asks you if
he looks good in this dress you know
little little white lies that might hurt
somebody's feelings otherwise and I
think the ones that maybe try to avoid
them are the bigger ones that maybe you
lock yourself in to the challenge with
line is that you have to remember your
lies for the next time it comes up and
keeping track of all your stories can be
a challenge in my business I really
value honesty and openness and it's
something that I encourage for my team
and I think if you're going to make
important business decisions and you
need to have the right information and
the key to getting that out of your team
is one you being honest with people
right giving them honest feedback
sometimes it may be harsh and you can
you can soften it and you can encourage
them to get better but given the honest
feedback on what's wrong I try to
surround with other people who like
getting that feedback who then want to
grow and continue to get better and then
also not punishing people when they give
you honest feedback right if you are
attacking somebody for telling you that
they made a mistake then they're not
going to tell you the next time they're
gonna lie about it
so make sure you're not giving them that
punishment they'll encourage anyone to
come back keep doing it again for you
just as a quick example I'm taking over
a company right now and we have 50
people on the team and I needed to hire
somebody to run it because I don't have
time to run it I'm doing this stuff for
you guys and I'm happy to coach and
mentor and train but I don't want to be
the CEO so I hired somebody away from
his job and he's at this big job you
know big company
no worries about security and any other
issues kind of all taken care of and I
convinced him to come work for me
and take on this slightly riskier
opportunity but grow something a lot
more successful and have more growth for
him because I answered everything
honestly right and I try to take that
approach I may not always have the best
answer and I may not always have the
answer that you want but it was
something that he appreciated and he
knows that every time that he comes to
me I'm gonna give him my honest feedback
and an honest answer and hopefully we
can use that information to keep moving
forward at the same time in the business
we've got eight key staff members that
are important positions and I met with
them all individually and I met with
them all as a group to understand what
they liked what they didn't like how it
can make things better how it could
improve and encouraged again honest
feedback like tell me what you don't
like tell me what we can fix and that
really helped us build the relationship
up and hopefully continue that honest
dialogue one of the most consistent
feedback that I've gotten from everybody
they understand there's things that
could be improved they understand that
you know I want to run things in a
different way but what they love is that
they always say I appreciate your
transparency your openness and your
honesty
so the question of the day today is is
it ever okay to tell a lie and if so
when leave a comment below and I'm gonna
join in the discussion thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events Russell
this prey so give me go